hey florida it's me conan o'brien here
to talk to you about
voting even though 98 of my fans can't
go to the polls because they're either
pre-teens or convicted felons
that won't stop me from addressing you
the voters of florida
once again you're playing a crucial role
in picking our president
so whatever you do don't forget to vote
forgetting to vote would be like going
into a public supermarket to order the
boar's head maple honey turkey sub
with the saint andre soft ripe and
cheese and then forgetting the
mayonnaise
or like forgetting you retired and moved
to brookville florida
to play golf at the fabled pine barrens
golf course
but instead decided to play quarterback
for the tampa bay buccaneers
and if you're gonna vote by mail vote
early
because this year the postal service may
be slower than a
senior on the dale mabry highway who
just realized they missed the turn off
for the courtney campbell bridge to
clearwater
yes i know my florida
so florida remember october 5th voter
registration deadline
you can do it online at when we all vote
dot org